uh yes hello and we have a very special
guest today hello Mike so I'm here with
Mike Isaacson so you're an artistic
director and an executive producer of
The Minis can you tell me a little bit
about the music and how important a land
market is in St Louis well uh that's a
great question
like the St Louis chess club and the St
Louis Chess Hall of Fame World Chess
Hall of Fame
um it is a singular International
National Institution right here in St
Louis
we're in our 105th season and it is the
world's largest outdoor theater there
are 11 000 seats
we produce seven
huge Broadway musicals this summer we
perform for thousands of people each
night and each night we also have um
1500 free seats so anybody from the
community can come it's a huge tradition
here in life in St Louis it's usually
about a life of going to musicals at the
muni in our beautiful Forest Park during
the summer which is
three blocks from you know here we are
at the chess club and it's just this
incredible beautiful tradition and
people just love it and we have this
connection to the worldwide musical
theater Community Broadway London people
come from all over the world to perform
on our stage and we have like the top
talent Tony Award winners Olivier Road
winners incredible designs and it's a
huge part of life in in St Louis and um
something we're really proud of
I've been in producer and and director
I know a lot about you please reveal us
the secrets about the new coming
upcoming season and especially about the
chess Musical
so uh uh as you said I'm the artistic
director and executive producer and sort
of my real uh job
besides being responsible for everything
that's on the stage when you see the
show that night at the Muny is just sort
of really understand the audience and
what excites them and their imagination
and chess has been a dream of mine since
this is my 12th season since I walked in
the door because it is this like it's
like the greatest musical you've never
heard it is a wonderful wonderful
Musical that was an international hit
and this is our first time at the muni
uh it's a real premiere for us first
time we've done the show which I am so
excited about the music it first began
as a album an incredibly popular album
around the world uh in the late 80s
and it sold internationally there was a
song One Night in Bangkok that became a
dance hit somewhere there was a duet I
know him so well all these songs the
music's by the guys who did all the
album music and the lyrics are by Tim
Rice who did Jesus Christ Superstar and
Evita and all these great musicals and
so it's this incredibly Rich Bold Rock
and rolled score in music and told in
this incredibly vibrant Styles and um
people just love it and a weird thing
happened with it historically they first
did it in London and it was a huge hit
ran for four years and just it was a
massive hit then they brought it for
Broadway for reasons I don't know why
they decided to change the script change
a lot and it didn't work it closed very
quickly on Broadway but it was sort of
still this legendary show and it went
out on a national tour in a different
form but it continued to be popular
worldwide world of mouth PBS did a big
concert version with Josh Groban Idina
Menzel it's been done it's been done in
Russia it's been done in the Far East
all over the place so finally because of
the St Louis chess club and the World
Chess Hall of Fame we have this amazing
partnership and we can bring it to the
muni and we're going to use the original
London script we're going to use what
was a huge hit which basically
celebrates the Glorious music of the
show and it's really really exciting and
on everyone in St Louis is so excited
about it and we've already anticipated
my question but what is your personal
vision of the musical well
you know there's nothing greater that
when you go to the theater or and you're
surprised you walk in and you think I
don't know what this is and it takes you
on a journey and you love the music and
you find the characters and you just you
know you get an experience that
transports and you know time is on our
side because as if you're watching this
you know chess has never been more
popular in the United States it's
incredible thanks to the great work of
everyone here so we're Landing it right
A Moment Like even people who don't know
chess are curious about it and why is
everybody talking about it so this the
story within the show tells the story of
an international chess tournament
Russians versus the US and the the two
men playing and of course the second
four uh one is a woman who maybe falls
in love with another so you sort of get
this sense of intrigue and personal
stake but you know everything that's
been explored in popular culture right
now with the Queen's gamut and all the
things you know people are really
interested in like why why does someone
play the game why is this game so
popular through history there's a song
in the show The Story of Chess that
gives you how chess came about
um so it's hitting it right the moment
people are really curious and excited
well I had a question for you know I was
born in the Soviet Union Yes and well
I've lived through these chess stories
but on the other side and I wanted to
ask a personal question for example how
did it touch you personally when Bobby
Fischer played the match against Boris
fosky
well I was young then or younger let's
say that what I remember what a great
question what I remember so specifically
is
this was going on and clearly it was
important
and it was it was a game being played
like you know I knew Sports and
Athletics the other day of game but this
I knew was different like the the stakes
of it and the idea of what it meant to
the world I'd never seen anything like
that before like that was new to me at
the time like oh a game matters
worldwide I mean you sort of have it
with the Olympics I guess but that's its
own a different kind of energy this was
I remember it was just in in the papers
remember newspapers it was in the papers
every day and it was on TV and
everything about it was so and it was
sort of the thing where you went oh I
need to investigate this
and I'll admit I I did play chess I was
terrible I played it a lot in high
school I was not successful at it so uh
I'm aware of the game but I don't play
it because I'm not good
well thank you so much for this
wonderful interview and I'm actually
looking forward to the chess musical
because I've seen it several times I
love the music isn't the music great
it's fantastic music yeah yeah okay so
and please come everyone Everyone's
Watching come to St Louis come teach us
thank you very much Mike thank you very
very good luck with the with the shows